(uplifting music)
- [Narrator] Most of rural Kenya
doesn't have access to electricity.
This means the evenings
are full of darkness.
Here, families rely on kerosene lamps,
which are expensive and
produce harmful fumes.
John Wangare wanted to change that.
- My name is John Margiro Wangare.
I am the found of Magiro
Mini Hydroelectric.
- [Narrator] Inspired by the
dynamo on his brother's bicycle
that generated light
once the wheel turned,
John had an idea.
What if that simple mechanism
could be made bigger?
And what could turn that wheel?
- [Narrator] From there, John
started to make his power plant
with pieces of scrap.
Using the river, John was
able to move the turbine,
thus generating electricity.
Slowly but surely, Magiro Power started
to produce clean energy.